in the last video you saw how to define
the content cost function for neuro
style transfer mix let's take a look at
the style cost function so what is the
style of an image mean let's say you
have an input image like this you're
used to seeing a confident like that
compute features that there is different
hidden layers and let's say you've
chosen some layer L maybe that layer to
define the measure of the style of an
image what we're going to do is define
the style as the correlation between
activations across different channels in
this layer L activation so here's what I
mean by that let's say you take that
layer L activations so this is going to
be a niche by NW by NC block of
activations and we're going to ask how
correlated are the activations across
different channels so to explain what I
mean by this may be slightly cryptic
phrase let's take this block of
activations and let me shade the
different channels there are different
colors so in this lower example we have
say five channels and which is why I
have five shades of color here in
practice of course in your network we
usually have a lot more channels than
five but using just five makes the
drawing easier but to capture the style
of an image what you're gonna do is the
following let's look at the first two
channels let's look at the red Channel
and the yellow Channel and say how
correlated are activations in these
first two channels so for example in the
lower right hand corner you have some
activation in the first channel and some
activation in the second Channel
so that gives you a pair of numbers and
what you do is look at different
positions across this block live active
ations and just look at those two pairs
of numbers one in the first channel the
red channel one in the yellow channel
the second channel and you just look at
these two pairs of numbers and see when
you look across all of these positions
all of these and H bar and W positions
how correlated are these two numbers so
why does this capture style
let's look at an example here's one of
the visualizations from the earlier
video this comes from again the paper by
Matthews either and brought ferger's
that had reference earlier and let's say
for the sake of arguments that the event
neuron corresponds to and let's say for
the sake of arguments that the red
channel corresponds to this neuron says
trying to figure out if does this in a
little vertical texture or in a
particular position in the image and
let's say that this second channel this
yellow second channel corresponds to
this neuron which is you know vaguely
looking for orange colored patches so
what does it mean for these two channels
to be highly correlated well if they're
highly correlated what that means is
whenever part of the image has this type
of a subtle vertical texture that part
of the image will probably have this
orange tint and what does it mean for
them to be uncorrelated well it means
that whenever there is this vertical
texture it's probably won't have that
orange tint and so the correlation tells
you which of these high level texture
components tend to occur or not occur
together in part of an image and it's
the degree of correlation that gives you
one way of measuring how often these
different high level features such as
vertical texture or this orange tint or
other things as well how often they
occur and how often they occur together
and don't occur together in different
parts of an image and so if we use the
degree of correlation between channels
as a measure of the style then what you
can do is measure the degree to which in
your generated image this first channel
is correlated or uncorrelated with the
second channel and that will tell you in
the generated image how often this type
of vertical texture occurs or doesn't
occur with this orange tint and this
gives you a measure of how similar is
the style of the generated image to the
style of the input style image
so let's now formalize this intuition
for each of the two images the star
image and the generated image you're
going to compute a style matrix so more
formally let's say that you're using
layer L to measure the style let's let
any subscript IJ K be the activation at
position ijk in that hidden layer L so
this indexes into the position height
width and this indexes into the
different channels so what you're going
to do is compute a style matrix for
layer L and for the style image and this
will be a NC by NC dimensional matrix
and you do the same thing for the
generated image as well but now let's
define this style image so ye define
using layer L and on the style image
it's going to be a matrix where the
height and width of this matrix is the
number of channels by number of channels
so in this matrix the k k prime element
is going to measure how correlated our
channels K and K Prime so more formally
let me define this as sum over I sum
over J of the activation at position I J
of channel K times the activation at the
same position I J for that channel K
Prime and just multiply these two things
together so I and J sum over the height
and width right at that layer L so you
summing over the different positions the
X&Y positions who is finally height and
width and then just multiplying out the
activations
at channel K with channel K Prime and so
far I've been using the term correlation
technically this is the unnormalized
cross covariance because we're not
subtracting a mean and you're just
multiplying all these things so this is
going to be the style matrix for the
input style image s and then you do the
same thing for the generated image so
this is going to be really the same
thing sum from J equals 1 equals n WL of
the same thing
IJ K a subscript IJ a subscript IJ K
Prime now and if you want to distinguish
these activations I guess you could put
a superscript round bracket s and G just
to distinguish that these are the
activations on the sow images and on the
generator image G and we denote these
matrices using the capital alphabet G
because in linear algebra this is
sometimes also called the DRAM matrix
but I'm just gonna call this the style
matrix in this video oh sorry just pick
up KK prime there right so these are the
formulas for defining the KK prime
elements of this NC by NC square matrix
so what you're going to do is given an
image computes something called a style
matrix which will measure all those
correlations we talked about on the last
slide so more formally let's let a
superscript L subscript IJ K denote the
activation at position ijk in hidden
layer L so I indexes into the height J
indexes into the width and K index
across the different channels so in the
previous slide we had five channels but
K will index across those five channels
so what the style matrix will do is
you're going to compute a matrix we call
this G superscript around the square
bracket L this is going to be an NC by
NC dimensional matrix so be a square
matrix remember you have NC channels and
so you have an NC by NC dimensional
matrix in order to measure how
correlated each pair of them is so
particular
g/l ke k prime will measure how
correlated are the activations in
channel k prepared to the activations in
channel k prime where here k and k prime
will range from 1 through and see the
number of channels there are in that
layer so more formally the way you
compute G L and I'm just going to write
down the formula for computing 1
elements of the KK prime elements of
this this is going to be sum of I sum of
a J of the activation in that layer IJ K
times the activation at i j k prime so
here remember I and J index across the
different positions in the block indexes
over the height and width so I is the
sum from 1 to N H and J is a sum from 1
to N W and K here and K prime index over
the channel so K and K Prime range from
1 to the total number of channels in
that layer of the neural network so all
this is doing is is summing over the
different positions of the image over
the height and width and just
multiplying the activations together of
the channels K and K Prime and that's
the definition of G cake
and you do this for every value of K and
K Prime to compute this matrix G also
called the style matrix and so notice
that if both of these activations tend
to be lashed together then G KK prime
will be launched where as that they are
uncorrelated then G QJ prime might be
small and technically I've been using
the term correlation to convey intuition
but this is actually the unnormalized
cross covariance because we're not
subtracting out the mean and this is
just multiplying how these elements
directly so this is how you compute the
style of an image and you'd actually do
this for both the style image s and for
the generated image G so just to
distinguish that this is the style image
you know maybe let me add a round
bracket s there just to denote that this
is the style image for the image s and
those are the activations on the image s
and what you do is then compute the same
thing for the generated image so it's
really the same thing
some of rice some of you J AI j k l AI j
k hello um and the summation indices are
the same right as follows and you wanna
just to note this is for the generated
image I'll just put the round practice G
there so now you have two matrices they
capture whether it's the style of the
image s and what is the style of the
image G and by the way I we've been
using the alphabet to capital G to
denote these matrices in linear algebra
these are also called the gram matrix
all these are called gram matrices but
in this video I'm just going to use the
term style matrix but this is term gram
matrix that motivates using capital
to denote these matrices finally the
cost function the style cost function if
you're doing this on layer L between s
and G you can now define that to be just
the UM you can now define that to be
just the difference between these two
matrices GL G squared and these are
matrices so I'll just take the previous
long so this is just the sum of squares
of the element-wise differences between
these two matrices and just the right
result this is going to be sum over k
sum of a k prime of these differences s
K prime minus G L g k k prime and then
the sum of squares of elements the
authors actually use this for
normalization constants two times R and
H and W that layer and see that layer
and then square this you can you know
put this up here as well but the
normalization constant doesn't matter
that much because this cost is
multiplied by some hyper parameter B
anyway so just to finish up this is the
style cost function defined using layer
L and as you saw under previous line
this is basically the Frobenius norm
between two style matrices computed on
the image s and on the image G for
business on squared and then we read
additional normalization constant which
isn't that important and finally it
turns out that you get more visually
pleasing results if you use the style
cost function from multiple different
layers so the overall style cost
function
you can define as sum over all the
different layers of the style cost
function for that layer you should
define the book weighted by some set of
parameters by some set of additional
hyper parameters which you only know as
lambda L here so what this does is
allows you to use different layers in
the neural network both the early ones
which measure relatively simpler
low-level features like edges as well as
some later layers which measure high
level features and cause the neural
network to take both low level and high
level correlations into account when
computing style and in the program
exercise you gain more intuition about
what might be reasonable choices for
this hyper parameter lambda as well and
so just to wrap this up you can now
define the overall cost function as
alpha times the content cost between C
and G plus beta times the style cost
between s and G and then use gradient
descent or a more sophisticated
optimization algorithm if you want in
order to try to find an image G that
human eyes that tries to minimize this
cost function J or P and if you do that
you can generate pretty good-looking
neuro artistic and if you do that you'll
be able to generate some pretty nice
novel artwork so that's it for neural
style transfer and I hope you have fun
implementing it in this week's for an
exercise before wrapping up this week
there's just one last thing on my share
of you which is how to do convolutions
over 1d or 3d data rather than over only
2d images let's go on to the last video